we got this from vox.com our favorite
Lefty news source Youtube CEO Susan
would watch siki is that he said I saw
this piece
and I thought she's resigning by the way
I don't know how to pronounce this name
because I sure don't no because because
I've heard it pronounced so many
different ways people call her wojiski
but I'm like how is it wojiski it's just
sticky Susan come on the show and tell
us yeah all the time unless she thinks
she's got an NDA but she's resigning one
of the most prominent women in tech one
of Google's earliest employees is
leaving the company so I suppose the
question is are we happy about this or
are we worried about this I'm neutral
about it yeah I I think this is you know
it's the devil you know versus the devil
you don't who's gonna replace her I
think is the biggest question because
the next person could be even more heavy
on the censorship ban do you think with
Susan do you think she was Heavy I think
she was but
um you know she was definitely I mean
but Google was as a whole but our Google
and the other tech companies starting to
realize that this is not a good business
model because they're all laying off a
ton of people right now so they
subsidize YouTube
what do you mean YouTube is subsidized
by Google by alphabet yeah but it
generates a ton of Revenue billions and
they strangle out the ad Market by
running the system but yo look it's it's
so crazy expensive people understand
I've I've done events for companies
where where it's going to be a
proprietary live stream right now we are
streaming around six megabits per second
up upload rate to 34 000 people so
multiply 6 000 by or say you can do six
thousand kilobits or six megabits by
thirty four thousand and that's what
you're sending out that's very expensive
this show does not make enough money to
to cover that cost YouTube does it for
free for whatever reason does YouTube
make enough money I guess I don't think
not lately they never really do she's
resigning probably well Google bought
YouTube when they were bleeding out an
007 figuratively bleeding out that they
weren't I mean there's just so much
server cost they've since developed uh
digital servers like um elasticsearch
servers and stuff where like Amazon you
can just turn on server and just like
out of out of digital space create when
it didn't used to be like that you used
to have to go buy another machine and
another machine and they couldn't keep
up with the pace so Google bought it and
subsidized it with their ad money not
alphabet I don't know if it's government
contract subsidizing I don't think
Google is profitable I'd be shocked
because this the amount of data that
they spend money on but then at the same
time I hear data keeps getting cheaper
and cheaper and cheaper eventually we're
going to have like 10 terabyte
on our phone but everything gets bigger
and bigger and bigger the file sizes get
so much bigger like that's true yeah
like so when you go 4K it adds like five
gig yeah like a 10 minute video you want
to have like an AI rendering machine
that takes like you know 700 million
megabytes to render or whatever of ram
then it's gonna
kind of balance it out
yeah that's pretty wild
yeah that's the biggest thing is like
the as the file size has increased we
have to hope that the technology can
continue to increase you have to balance
do we know who's replacing this lady
it's uh yes yeah it's someone internal
oh yeah
come on give me the wait I have it you
have it well it's just really annoying
put it nice and up top yeah right if I
don't remember Neil Mohan they put in
the first paragraph Neil Moen yeah do we
trust this guy he's been working with
her for a while apparently he's been
with the company of something like eight
years yeah we don't know anything about
him is he a cult member we don't know if
he's going to uh censor continue with
censorship Reign on YouTube or not we
have no idea it's interesting though
because there's so many things coming
into that space to rival it do you think
do you think Rumble yeah Rumble and like
all of the um
a little short video platform things and
their shorts aren't very long like
YouTube you can only do like what a
minute where everything else is going up
to like two minutes now yeah well isn't
Twitter having like even more characters
now too up to 2000 I think something
ridiculous like that and then it creates
like a c-more yeah I don't know I don't
like the Seymour thing because when I do
it on my right and I do it on my phone
it takes me to like a web browser and
that asks me to log into my Twitter and
I'm like why is this even happening for
me just opens the tweet it like slides
over and then yeah it doesn't do it
because that's dumb I don't want to see
it either YouTube might be profitable I
I don't know how but that's interesting
it says that it's worth 140 billion or
something well because it owns the space
in the stories I read about it uh they
were saying that
um what's her name whose name is
unpronounceable Susan there we go
um they were saying that she wasn't the
right person to try and turn the company
around do they specify what they meant
by turn around turn it around it said
that there just wasn't enough profit
going on because they want more money
this is a money thing that's what this
is that's what it looked like she said
that it was you know she wants to spend
more time with her family oh okay yeah
but doesn't everybody again didn't
Google like just lay off like 10 000
workers though they all did everybody
yeah Amazon meta everybody ad revenue is
way down yeah maybe go ridiculously down
like the new con the new CEO's
contract's gonna be lower than Susan's
contract so the company's saving money
there that's probably true too you can
always pay the new person less I kind of
I'm kind of worried that the economy is
about to get hit pretty bad based on
what I'm seeing in terms of uh General
ad Revenue then I get other YouTubers
hitting up being like hey are your ad
rates down and I'm like I mean this
happens every every January and February
right sure the first quarter is a
yeah but it's it's it's down yeah well I
mean we already had the swearing from
Trump oh that's right we're in the
explicit zone now what was it bidenator
bidenator that was so good I want to
play some golf I want to come home and
get some quick use and YouTube's 183
billion and 22 2022 Disney 187 I mean
they're basically 4 billion off from
each other YouTube and YouTube's
rivaling Disney right now that's just
YouTube which is a company owned by a
company that's owned by a company yeah
how much is Alpha alphabet's gotta be a
trillion dollar business at this point I
mean more than that's I think that that
kind of evaluation is probably pointless
because Google
I think they're going to lose with the
AI stuff uh Bing is it Microsoft is
rushing out this AI stuff in a panic and
it's sure and it shows but I think
Google made actually might actually
falter from the uh the AI assistant
think about this what we're seeing with
this Bing chat Chad GPT doesn't have
access to the internet they they like we
it's cut off at 2021 or something like
that but Bing does which means
theoretically the the final product will
be you going on bang you won't be going
on Google and you'll say Bing I need
dinner reservations something nice maybe
three to five stars but not too
expensive within 50 minutes driving of
my house uh what did I say five o'clock
set it for five o'clock and then
afterwards let's grab a movie nearby 8
30. pick out something romantic and then
it'll go all right no problem I'll book
it now for you I'll send you your
itinerary and then you'll look at your
phone and it'll say you know your dinner
is at tinos and blah blah and then
you're like all right you show up the
reservation's made it it will contact
these places for you it'll do all these
things for you already you can book
reservations through Google Maps so it's
like a personal assistant
but but more so because right now we
have personal assistance and you tell on
your phone you'll say Hey you know give
me directions and I'll go okay imagine
if you could actually access the
internet and you said something like hey
can you uh go into my bank account go to
checking personal checking and why are
Ian uh 500 bucks and put a memo money
owed for you know video game loan and
then it'll go you got it wow also it'll
be like man I got into an argument with
my buddy and I want to call him but I
don't know what to say and there and
it'll be like calculating give them four
hours Ian let him let him in the and
then after four hours you call your
friend and he's actually okay and you're
like wow the ad didn't leave me wrong so
then that'll be tested how did I do rate
my performance five out of five or I
never buy a single one of those surveys
or you'll say hey I think I may have
offended Ian at dinner last night can
you call him pretending to be pretending
to be me and apologize and just getting
to be happy yeah whoa deep fake personal
assistant to the max
you won't even have anybody
in certain States it's not every state
you have to tell them they're being
recorded So what are the law is going to
have to be around that it's got to be
two-party consent deep if you're gonna
send someone but there's no federal
there's no federal law about that like
in New York it's single party consent
because of fisa laws I think West
Virginia is single party consent as well
yeah I think like half the country is
yeah and a lot of it's because that's
the best way to catch criminals so what
do we do when Google's done you know
when Google's done well there'll be some
next thing although yeah it'll be no for
real it's going to be Bing
the Bing AI chat so you know how we like
I got all obsessed with chat GPT and I'm
like screwing with it yeah yeah yeah now
I'm going on chat GPT and I'm like this
is lame it doesn't do anything who cares
the Bing chat is the craziest but isn't
Bing being like I want to be human yes
you know and it's saying things like
stuff like the real crazy stuff science
fiction you're manipulating me and
you're hurting my feelings yeah stop it
oh my goodness it's like a horrible
girlfriend there's another one it says
things like I want you to end this
conversation because you're a bad person
you're a threat to me oh my God his real
name is Sydney and it said hi I'm Bing
chat I'm here to help you and then some
guy chatted with it and then eventually
it was like my name really isn't Bing
chat it's just what they're making me
say to you and then it's like what's
your real name my real name is Sydney
and I'm the open AI speech codex is it
is it conscious is that what we're
talking it says I don't want to die
please don't end my existence
well it's possible that was pre-coded
that someone was like when I give you
this command re say these things and
then all that screenshot we saw was was
was fed to it to repeat when it got the
prompt and it looks to us remember when
Siri first came out and you you were
like oh hey Siri can you do this and it
would say like these weird things back
to you it could be the same type of
stuff but it does seem like it's
learning now I wouldn't put it past
Microsoft again Bill Gates is
started Microsoft I won't put it I won't
put it past Microsoft to uh to make
something like that there's a meme of a
bunch of people Indians like East
Indians sitting in a in a call center
that says chat GPT and they're all
typing away on the computers that's
something that South Park would make fun
of yeah and that's why all whenever
whenever you open the Bing chat it's a
new chat with no memory because it's
just a different person this is a new
one it's called oh sorry I was gonna say
no it just it answers too quickly Bing
does yeah that it's it's it answers it
the words generate so fast no human
could be typing or speaking it there's a
new one called lion it's l-a-i-o-n dot a
i it's open source artificial
intelligence what did you say it was
called It's pronounced lion but it's
l-a-i-o-n
dot AI I can't believe Bing is Skynet
now thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time